[Musique]
vous avez des générations de jeunes
députés qui ont été élus dans la foulée
de l'élection d' emmanuel macron en 2017
qui n'ont aucune attache pour les
antiennes territoriales locales il faut
que les parlementaires puissent être la
caisse de résonance et très occupation
des citoyens qui puisse leur remontée au
parlement et c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui un sujet qu'il fallait en
parler et moi mon propos c'est justement
d'ouvrir le débat on peut pas avoir deux
types d lui ceux qui sont au parlement
et ceux qui sont dans les territoires il
faut relier le parlement et des
territoires il faut que les
parlementaires et des racines dans les
territoires et des pieds dans les
territoires et je crois que ce serait
une bonne chose
[Musique]